each of the Big Bang Theory characters
is Iconic in their own right but there's
only one fans new and loved for her
voice alone excuse me Mr groundup
Howard's mom Mrs walowitz was voiced by
Caroline Susie she was heard on 40
episodes of the CBS series the number
one TV sitcom for close to 8 years
running the character was known for her
unbeatable brisket for her domineering
approach to parenting for coddling her
son and his friends and for almost never
appearing on screen the show's creators
delay liely kept Mrs walowitz to just
her booming New Jersey accented voice
although they occasionally tease Their
audience with a tantalizing Glimpse see
your Fitness was cancelled it turns out
you can forget how to ride a bike in the
24th episode of the fifth season this is
walowitz can be seen dressed in pink
among the guests at Howard and
Bernadette's wedding as the camera pulls
away from the rooftop and in the 15th
episode of season 6 gaj visits Mrs
walowitz for one of her famously huge
dinners and viewers briefly see her
through the kitchen doorway way walking
back and forth in a floral dress I've
had a lovely time eating your brisket
and hearing about the things you've had
removed from your body over the yours
The Big Bang Theory Creator and
executive producer Chuck Lori created
Mrs wtz to be another in a prestigious
collection of sitcom characters who are
heard but never seen notably he wanted
to reference Carlton the doorman from
Roa a spin-off of the Mary Tyler Moore
Show that ran from 1974 to
1978 hello this is Carlton your doorman
in 2012 Susi told the plane dealer that
she wasn't sure if Mrs walowitz would be
a recurring character until after her
second episode when Lori told her
Carlton the doorman that's the kind of
thing we're going for here he said you
don't mind not seeing the hair and
makeup people for the next 10 years and
I said not at all as long as I get paid
Lori never publicly expounded on the
thought process behind Mrs walowitz
however before the Big Bang Theory
season 6 aired executive producer Steve
mararo shared with The Hollywood
Reporter that the shot of her at her son
Howard's wedding was supposed to be the
first and last time audiences ever saw
her saying isn't she better left to the
imagination there are no plans to
actually see her on camera and I think
it's probably better that way but Mrs
walowitz did appear once more and the
surprise was worth the slight deception
from a story perspective hiding a
character can build them up in a way
that can be far more comical than any
real person cow tipping real or not I'm
going to say not that's just based on me
trying to roll my mom over when she's
snoring given that we did Glimpse Mrs
wtz again after the wedding there's a
chance would have appeared on future
episodes but when actress Caroline Susi
died of cancer on November 11th 2014
series producers couldn't imagine
replacing her instead they had Mrs wtz
pass away on the show as well in tribute
to the actress and her character The Big
Bang Theory carried on the Trope of the
herd but unseen figure that dominates
Howard's life on season 10 episode 11
bernardet gives birth to baby Haley
whose cries sound eerily like her
paternal grandmother's
[Music]
voice
[Applause]
and like Mrs wallts we never see the
baby on screen outside of enormous
swaddles of blankets Mar to TV line is
partly a practical issue babies on set
are a logistical nightmare but first and
foremost it was a way to honor Mrs wtz
Malo shared Haley is a loving tribute to
her grandmother this is a nice way for
us to keep Mrs wtz alive the woman with
the unmistakable voice and mouthwatering
brisket may have been out of sight but
she was only ever perfectly delivered
line away from stealing a scene and the
audience's
[Music]
hearts